[Music]
john fabro i tried to teach him how to
cook we did an event and he said you
know i cook too and everything i said
okay
make an omelet and i had him make an
omelet and i said this is ready for the
garbage can so i put it in the garbage
can and he was sweating it was a lot of
fun because he always thinks he's such a
good cook
hello i'm wolfgang puck and this is a
[Music]
breakdown
have you decided this evening your soup
is is excellent
but we order it every time yeah what
else do you have
something else we have a very nice folk
wow i know about the foreground
the old standby used to be famous for it
what does the chef have that's
new our customers always ask for
special dishes or for special
ingredients
we have a lot of vegan customers and so
forth for us in the kitchen is almost
normal now to accommodate everybody not
totally everybody but whatever we can do
i think it's really an important part in
the restaurant business
to accommodate the guests because they
have many choices if we don't
accommodate them
somebody else might what are you doing
you're supposed to be preparing the
gusto recipe
this is this is the recipe the recipe
doesn't go for white truffle oil what
else have you been
you are improvising this is no time to
experiment because while waiting
i love the improvisation in cooking
cooking to me is like
painting you can add a little more
pepper or a little more olive oil or
some different kinds of herbs and spices
and you make a completely different dish
you can make it taste like it came out
of morocco or out of persia
or out of france just by adding
different spices
you know it really looks like it is a
french restaurant the way it's set up
and the way they're cooking and in the
copper pans it looks like a french
restaurant to me i love it
asking about it about linguini i have
seven more orders that's
wonderful creation really comes in
seconds and sometimes you create
something it will take a long time like
for me to perfect
a chinese style duck like a baking duck
it took me
uh maybe weeks but to making the smoked
salmon pizza we always made
smoked salmon and then one day i
was serving smoked salmon with brioche
and one day we ran out of bread so
i just cooked the pizza bread and served
it on the side and then
it came to my mind like at that moment i
said
why don't i put just everything together
so i put it together put caviar on it
gave it to joan collins and she said
wow this is my pizza this is the joan
collins pizza
i really like my kitchen to be organized
chaos
it looks chaotic but if you're
professional it's actually
like an orchestra everybody plays their
instrument to perfection
you have the chef orchestra the director
and then you have different stations so
you have the stations where they do
all the appetizers maybe all the cold
appetizers then you have a station
for the warm appetizers then you have a
station for fish then you have a station
where you do all the meat
even if it's difficult you can handle it
but if it's not
organized then it becomes chaotic
next up chef
[Music]
john fabro i tried to teach him how to
cook i remember when he came to the
bellaire hotel one time we did an event
and he
said you know i cook too and everything
i say okay make an omelet and i had him
make an omelet and i said this is ready
for the garbage can so i put it in the
garbage can and he was sweating
it was a lot of fun so i tried to give
him a hard time because he always thinks
he's such a good cook
this is an interesting clip because jon
favreau to me at least should be the
chef
not the prep cook he worked like a prep
cook there so
in a way the organization is not really
straightened out
but if he didn't have anybody to cook
with or nobody showed up he had to do it
[Music]
i really think that the knife technique
you could see
it was from somebody else not from jon
fabo slicing that fast i think i would
be scared if he would have a sharp knife
and slice that fast
a lot of people have different thoughts
about how many knives you really need
let's say if you have six knife or eight
knives and the
sharpening steel and the peeler and the
grader and
things like that so i really believe you
need
a box and these days the every chef
comes with his own little case
and has his knives because i think it's
really an important part
to have really sharp knives you don't
want to use a knife you
slice smoked salmon with and then use
that to cut a bone because you will
break the knife and put dance in it and
then it's useless
prep work starts in the morning like we
go to the fish market to the farmer's
market
find the best ingredients and then
decide what to cook
sometimes we bring all the sous chefs
together and says what do you do with
the santa barbara shrimps what would you
do
with the hamachi what would you do with
fennel and
new tomatoes let's fast forward
no come over here give us water
[Music]
he was checking if the grill is hot so
he put water on it but you have to be
careful not to put cold water on it so
i think for me i just check it with my
hand i know if it's hot
i don't touch the grill just put the
hand over it and you can feel the heat
but for the inexperienced one you have
to put water in it
oh look at that see how golden that is
that's how you want it to be every time
you gotta be like a robot
you know i really love to use the panini
grill
i use it in my home very often to cook a
steak
to cook fish my wife loves it the panini
grill is really a great way to cook
because he cooks
a dish from both sides now here they
were making a cuban sandwich
you want it to be cooked and pressed at
the same time
i really believe the cuban sandwich has
to be nice and crunchy and crispy in the
outside because it's this french
baguette a simple
pagetto you know not a sourdough and
then the inside
gets warm also i like when the whole
sandwich
warms it up the cheese melts so you get
all the flavors combined together with
the mustard the pickles whatever you put
in it so you have different temperatures
and different textures which makes a
sandwich from
just ordinary to extraordinary
[Music]
you only can fit that much stuff into a
truck
i designed a truck specially you know we
had one catering truck like that
and it was fun for one day or for two
days but it's a complicated thing it
looks so easy but you have to go back to
a place where the inspectors
check everything so it's not an easy
thing to drive around in a truck
it's certainly not for me i said why
should i drive in a truck
and why should i serve people standing
in the street
if i have a beautiful restaurant and
many beautiful restaurants really so no
truck for me
i have never eaten out of a truck and i
don't intend to
because to me if i eat it's a special
moment
i'm never that hungry that i say oh my
god let's stop at this
truck stop and get a hamburger or
taco or whatever it is standing in the
street and eating for me
is not an experience next up no
reservation
the guy table seven said if you wanted
it cremated it wouldn't have
rare that is rare
apparently not rare enough rare or
medium rare or medium
is an established way of cooking things
if it's done the right way rare is
cooked really in the outside
that the inside is warm or hot
but not really cooked and sometimes
people
don't understand it quite and i have
customers sometimes and says
this is not medium rare and i said what
do you mean it's not medium rare
but they really wanted medium well you
know
some people say medium rare but they
don't know what it is actually look
these are ad agency people they spend a
lot of money here no tantrums and i just
fire another one i generally
don't try to argue with the customers
because it gets me upset and maybe the
customers do so i just say okay you know
what they don't know exactly what they
mean
we have to wait out the manager go to
the customer says would you like it a
little more cooked
and we don't try to make them feel bad
in front of their
friends or family or business partners
whatever it is
i don't want to say what you don't know
what the rare is this is rare so then he
will feel bad and might not come back
let me ask on seven again he wants to
know whether you've ever seen a rare
steak before
when i was young i would get so upset i
used to go and confront the customers
especially when i cooked fish i remember
one time
ray stark a famous hollywood producer he
said i want my hollywood really dry
i said why do you want it dry he said
that's the way i like my fish
so i went cooked it really dry maybe
made it
extra dry i left it longer in the oven
than it even needed
and then he complained to the waiter my
fish is so dry
i went out to him and says you know what
if you let me cook the way i think the
fish should be cooked
you would be a happy man but you don't
know how to cook a fish
that's my profession you make movies and
he just looked at me and said
what an arrogant ass this chef is so he
never came back
all right thanks for watching the clip
with me
stay tuned for part two